[silence]
>> Miya: And you should be good.
>> Stephan: Cool, hi, welcome back to another
VC Libraries open code review.
I'm Stephan T. Lavavej, an STL maintainer,
and today we'll be looking at a PR again,
PR 2158 extend memcpy,
memmove and memcmp optimizations
from our contributor Adam Bucior.
So let me go ahead and share out my screen.
And here we go.
'kay.
So resuming the review that I left
off last week, I got through up to
line, right line 4005 of <xutility>.
One of our central internal headers,
not the most central, but fairly central.
Contains lots of commonly used algorithms,
so we'll be resuming there.
Adam also pushed one commit to update a
comment. So, let's just check that.
It adds a comma, addressing the one comment
I had from the last time, excellent.
OK, so that's good.
Uh, let's get this to disappear.
OK, so, let's go look at the code.
We got all the product code
reviewed except for <xutility> and
then we've got tests to look at.
OK, so let's load this diff.
Scroll down to, right line 4005.
I seem to recall, at least for
this top part I had chosen to split
left and right, rather than inline.
Let me see if… here's 4005, let
me see if the stuff below it
would benefit from being split.
This part kind of yes,
not massively… well yeah here,
here this is kind of a…
I guess it's a rename plus a refactoring.
The diff isn't quite to the
point where it's unreadable.
This is like, here this is,
uh, sort of almost looks like
unrelated code getting… uh, it's
jumping in and out of add/remove
because it sees these empty lines.
And the diff algorithm used can be
responsible for this sort of behavior.
This down here is enough that I
think I wanna use side by side, OK.
So let's do that, click the gear, split,
may as well hide whitespace changes.
I could also use the VS Code
GitHub extension, but I'm more
used to the web UI at this point.
The VS Code extension is very nice because
it lets you see an arbitrary amount of
context around the lines being edited,
you don't have to click more.
I should get used to using it.
OK, so here's where we reviewed <xutility>
up to but not including this line.
I always pay attention to my
inclusive/exclusive issues.
So go ahead and resolve this, and
let's pick up where we left off.
OK, so this is the _Copy_unchecked algorithm.
Here we are copying a range [_First, _Last)
to a destination iterator.
It's internal and it's unchecked,
saying that we are going to assume
that the iterator range is valid
and that we have sufficient space
in _Dest. We have outer layers, um,
like the publicly accessible std::copy
function that will perform iterator
debugging checks when possible to do
things like make sure that the first
and last iterators are not reversed.
If you accidentally say, like,
(v.end(), v.begin()), or if you mismatch
them into different containers, like,
uh, (v.begin(), v2.end()), that would be bad.
Or if the destination range does
not have enough space,
uh, we can detect that sometimes if we can,
umm, sense
how many elements are in the input
range by doing like a difference
on forward or better iterators.
And if the output range is forward or better,
and especially if it's a random access,
we can see whether we can form,
you know _Dest + N or next(_Dest, N)
and see if that's valid.
And then once we have verified
that the iterators are not reversed,
and that there's sufficient
space in the destination.
We can do what we call unwrap the
iterators down to either raw pointers
for contiguous things or unchecked class
types that don't do iterator debugging
logic to sort of avoid overhead,
especially in debug mode.
Uh, where we don't get inlining
or any fancy optimizations.
So that's what _Copy_unchecked is doing here.
We have a note as a reminder
that things other than just std::copy
will directly call this.
We don't usually note this,
but the pattern of having unchecked
helpers just exist to implement
the public functions is strong
enough that when there's direct
callers to something unchecked,
we did start adding some of these
comments here, just as a reminder.
OK,
so this is changing from
_Ptr_copy_cat to _Iter_copy_cat.
That's the rename because it's being
generalized, and _Trivially_copyable
changes to _Trivially_assignable
because here we are assigning over
elements that already exist,
this is not the uninitialized special
algorithm that will fill raw memory.
So this is correct.
This is that make the type traits
we're using more fine grained.
OK, so down here,
this looks like a ranges version
let me expand some context.
We've got the ranges helper _Copy_unchecked,
I can tell it's ranges because
it's got all this sentinel stuff.
Here, _Ptr_copy_cat,
renamed _Iter_copy_cat,
_Trivially_copyable changed to
_Trivially_assignable,
same rationale, writing to an
_Out that already exists and
not changing the sized_sentinel_for
thing: this is the ranges idea –
Trying to avoid using the word
concept to avoid confusion.
– the ranges idea that you can
have a range and in C++20 ranges
the sentinel that denotes the
end of the range does not have
to be the same type as the
iterator, so it's generalizing the
classic iterator pattern from C++98's STL,
and this allows you to have
ranges like, oh, I have a pointer
to a null terminated string,
and I know when I'm going to hit the end,
if you traverse it from front to back.
But I don't know exactly where
that's going to be until we
actually look at every element,
so the sentinel can be a
special type that says, hey,
I've reached the end of the range
if the iterator on the left
hand side of the comparison
is pointing to a null character.
So that's an example of a sentinel that
does not have the same type as the iterator.
Some sentinels can actually tell you
the size of a range, that happens for
things like forward or better iterators,
where they are the same type, where the
sentinel is the same type as the iterator.
You just do a classic difference.
It can also happen in some cases for
something I believe like a list,
where the list knows its own size,
but, uh, arbitrary iterators may not.
Uh, I may be incorrect
there is that wrong?
>> Casey: That's not exactly this one, right?
So sized_sentinel_for means that the
iterator and sentinel can tell
you the distance between them.
list is an example of a range
that's a sized range.
It knows its own size,
but the iterators and sentinels don't know
the distance between them.
>> Stephan: Thank you.
OK, I thought I was getting that wrong, and, uh…
>> Casey: you were close.
That's definitely, you know, list is the important example,
but it's the important example of the
other property than the one you
were looking at.
>> Stephan: Yeah, the sized_range, OK.
Awesome, so yeah,
and sized_sentinel_for
is definitely the one we want
here because at this point we're just
being given an iterator and a sentinel,
not an entire range.
OK, so this is good,
uh, let's scroll down some more.
Um, OK,
now we've got copy_n, the version
that takes N number of elements.
This is the
classic std version, uh,
there is no unchecked form because
we're doing the unchecking in here.
Umm, so _Ptr_copy_cat renamed _Iter_copy_cat,
_Trivially_copyable to _Trivially_assignable.
Yep, it's not the uninitialized form,
so all good.
We've got a _Copy_backward_unchecked.
Yeah, that looks good.
this is the internal version
taking bidirectional iterators.
_Ptr_copy_cat renamed _Iter_copy_cat,
_Trivially_copyable to _Trivially_assignable.
Yep, that's good.
Nothing about this would be different.
OK, _Move_unchecked,
_Ptr_move_cat, because we're gonna
move elements, is now _Iter_move_cat,
that's good, _Trivially_copyable
to _Trivially_assignable.
Yep, the elements already exist.
_Move_backward_unchecked, um, this
one goes in the opposite order,
which helps in certain overlapping cases.
Uh, _Ptr_move_cat to _Iter_move_cat,
that's correct, _Trivially_copyable
to _Trivially_assignable,
again, the elements exist,
so that's good.
OK, so now for something slightly different.
This is one of the things that Adam had called
out in his extensive PR notes that I really
appreciate. The changes to _Is_all_bits_zero,
so this is used by the fill
optimization that will call memset.
If we're gonna fill it with an element,
and if that element happens to be 0, uh,
we can just call mems… memset,
and it doesn't matter how many bytes it is,
as long as all of the bits of
that element type are zero.
I believe this is this was from a previous
generalization of our optimization.
This is being further extended to
handle nullptr_t, because
if we're being given an element,
say, say we're being asked to fill a
range of pointers, like char*s,
const char*s, whatever.
And the element that we're given to fill
happens to be nullptr, the literal constant.
That's saying, hey,
I want you to null out all these pointers.
So this will detect that hey,
if the element we're being given is nullptr_t,
we can just always return true.
And we can do so at compile time.
What this code would have done is it
would have made a constexpr for,
whoa, I'm zooming in a bit,
It would have made a constexpr
object of type nullptr,
and then memcmp'd it at runtime.
So we would get the answer
yes, it's all bits zero, but we would
have had to call memcmp to do so.
For nullptr we can just
statically detect it. So why not?
This improves codegen a little bit more.
And this does seem like a common enough
case to be worth optimizing, like fill
a range of pointers with nullptr,
maybe, they were uninitialized before,
maybe we need to reset them all.
Seems totally reasonable and
we can do this thanks to nullptr_t
being in the type system.
When things're in the type system,
that's good, when things like 0 is a
null pointer constant are rules that exist
outside the type system, that leads to misery,
as we saw from years and years
of experience with C++98.
So, if constexpr (is_same_v<_Ty, nullptr_t>)
then just always return true.
Otherwise do existing code.
This is correct because we are already
taking this thing by const _Ty&,
so we don't need to worry
about CV qualifiers.
is_same_v is very very strict.
It wants the type to be exactly identical
and any differences in constness or
volatility will cause this to report false.
Here this will ignore constness,
it ignores value category because
we're already taking it by reference,
so this is good.
And if somebody gives us a
volatile nullptr,
well they deserve what they get.
We'll go through this code path
and I think memcmp handles volatile?
I think it does.
Maybe it doesn't,
but in any event it's not going to
be a regression, so that's good.
And, I'm trying to think, are there any
other types that we could do this for?
Brain says no,
there's no other types that are like
nullptr_t, that we can just say hey,
you're always 0, every other type
Can store something useful.
Umm, OK, next, and I was just thinking,
um, that you could have something
like a struct who's only data member is
a nullptr, but we can't sense
that without, like, reflection, and plus
that would be very pathological/unusual.
>> Casey: empty types?
I wonder if empty types would be something interesting
to consider for that optimization.
>> Stephan: That's interesting.
It's like how often would you be
filling a range of empty types?
>> Casey: I dunno, how often do you fill a range of pointers?
[laughs] Ranges of pointers,
I'll admit, are a little more common, yes, but
>> Stephan: yeah, empty types,
you do see them as things like base classes,
you see them as things like tag types.
You don't really see ranges of them
because they would be stateless.
So although I'll admit yes,
we could potentially detect is_empty.
I think it would occur.
Yeah, I think it would occur so
infrequently that it wouldn't be worth
spending extra metaprogramming here,
yeah, but that's that's an interesting question.
>> Casey: [unintelligible] fallback to the compile time case?
I mean, sorry, the runtime case?
>> Stephan: Right, uh, yeah and this would say,
hey,
if it's constexpr and value init, it
will get, it would get the correct answer.
So at worst we get a little bit
extra runtime codegen.
OK, so now we've got more
metaprogramming logic
_Can_compare_with_operator_equal. This is asking…
I'm reading ahead of it.
Can we form the equality expression,
and then some of this pointer address
convertible stuff that we had before.
OK, so let's look at what's going on here.
template on _Ty1, _Ty2 and
then class default to void,
_INLINE_VAR is our macro that expands to
inline in C++17 mode and above.
We always want that for our constexpr
bools, or constexpr constants in general.
_Can_compare_with_operator_equal
defaults to false,
but if we meet criteria it can be true.
So this one here just looks wrapped
because of the narrow window here
for _Ty1 and _Ty2 this
is our void_t SFINAE pattern.
We basically say hey,
we're gonna write an expression that
we want, put it inside decltype to
get its type, and then smash that type
to void_t, uh, using void_t we're always
gonna get void out of this. So, if
this thing is well formed it will
be selected as the partial
specialization for this, uh,
because any use of this will use
this class equals void default.
This will be well formed and void
is more specific, so we'll take it.
But if this expression is not well formed,
then it SFINAEs away and you only
have the primary template available.
This is the void_t pattern for
SFINAE that we conventionally use
everywhere in the STL, and it… once
you learn the arcane trick behind it,
it is nice and terse,
and fairly simple to parse.
OK, so we form std::declval,
an imaginary value of type _Ty1&.
So we're gonna compare lvalues,
but we're not gonna add any sort of
constness, if we can say that's
== to a std::declval<_Ty2&>,
then, we can compare them with
operator==, because we usually compare
lvalues…
Which makes sense…
We would be calling this for
elements in a range?
Do I like lvalues there?
That's interesting.
Uh, I'm thinking about, oh, proxies,
if iterators, when dereferenced,
return proxies.
Am I comfortable with lvalue
references being added here?
I'm not sure, I'm going to
think about that for a bit.
Only, only very unusual types
would be sensitive to the difference,
vast majority of types don't care.
OK, so then we have a
separate variable template.
This is _Is_pointer_address_comparable.
This asks for a _Ty1 and _Ty2.
Can we compare the pointers,
_Ty1* and _Ty2*
with operator==?
Uh, for some this will be true,
Like, um, char* equals const char*,
that's totally valid.
But char* equals int*,
that's bogus, there's no such
conversions that could make that work,
so that would be false.
And then, regardless of what this reports,
because there's no short
circuiting at compile time,
uhm, we also asked the questions
is _Ty1 pointer address
convertible to _Ty2, or vice versa?
OK, this is interesting.
This is that thing that asks,
I think this was above,
Let me see if I can find it, pointer_address,
yeah this thing,
nope, that's the
first use, this, oh here it is.
OK. Nope, that's more use.
Was this in another header?
Oh here it is,
This says are they the same
after ignoring CVs and,
is it a base of, is _Dest the base of _Source?
Where they're pointer interconvertible,
meaning there's no pointer adjustments.
So, basically are the bits
literally the same,
if you convert from pointer
to _Source to pointer to _Dest,
which is true if you're just
adjusting CV qualifiers and
it's true if you're doing
this base transformation.
And we also special case,
oh, if any of them were void
pointer, uh, void*, then you can
certainly convert there.
I was briefly thinking about does this
report true for something like a void*
and a function pointer*,
which is… or a function* which is, maybe not?
But at least below we guard it with,
can we even form the equality?
Which is fine.
OK, so let's jump to that usage.
OK, so this is asking can we form the
equality expression between the pointers, and,
if we try to convert 1 to 2 or
2 to 1 because we don't know
exactly which order they've been given,
for example, it could be base* and
derived* or derived* and base*.
We just need one of those to be
pointer address convertible,
they don't both need to be.
Because the compiler,
when it performs the conversion,
will select the more de-, the more
base one to convert them to.
So if either of those are true,
then that means we can just
compare the pointers using memcmp.
OK, I think this all makes sense to me.
Um, the fact that _Can_compare_with_operator_equal
is always answering the
question means that we're not relying
on this to return whether they're
equality comparable at all, this is
merely refining, when this reports true.
I also see,
there's no real reason to refactor this
into terms of conjunction and disjunction.
There might be a small
throughput improvement.
To not have to ask these questions if it's
not comparable with operator equal at all.
I'm not too worried about that.
If we ever find throughput issues
we can always refactor this later.
Right now it's not really refactorable
because there's no struct version of this.
These are all, uh, variable templates,
so this is, this is good.
OK, so this is being used down here,
but there's one change happening here.
Um, this is in the implementation
of _Can_memcmp_elements.
Uh, previously we used to ask,
are they the same size?
And are they integral and non-volatile?
And then we have a specialization,
that handles if that's false, yes.
After all these, yeah.
So that's what that was doing.
This is being changed.
We're now going to permit volatile here.
We keep the size of _Elem1 and the size of _Elem2,
we keep _Elem1 integral, we keep
is_integral_v<_Elem2>.
This is clang-format being
kind of bad, but that's OK.
OK, uh, was it intended to
handle volatile here?
I need to look at the discussion notes.
Uh, let me just open up in tab 2158.
OK, this is _Can_memcmp_elements.
All these functions are named similarly, OK.
Pointers to pointer-interconvertible.
OK, this doesn't say anything about memcmp.
It says it disabled the memcpy and
memmove optimization for volatile,
but, this memcmp was already
disabling it for volatile.
So and now that nonvolatile
logic is being removed.
Why is this being removed? is_integral,
because this is a standard primary cat…,
uh, this is a standard type trait for
one of the primary type categories,
meaning the, sort of the entire
universe of types is divided up into
14 or so primary type categories
like integral, floating point,
nullptr, void, and a few others.
All of those ignore
top-level CV qualifiers.
So is_integral<int>, const int, volatile int,
and const volatile int are all true.
Here we were excluding volatile and
now it's no longer being excluded.
Does anything else handle
that here? This asks…
once we're satisfied that they're the
same type and they're both integral,
then you can memcmp if one or other is bool,
or if their negative
one values are the same,
then we handle bytes, we handle pointers.
Otherwise, we report false,
so this would report true for volatile int.
I don't understand why volatile is
being removed there.
Ah, OK. It's being lifted up a level.
This is asking _Can_memcmp_elements,
and we use it, uh,
I guess we have _Can_memcmp_elements_with_pred
in the middle here, yeah.
And then _Can_memcmp_elements_with_pred
is used here and the
_Equal_memcmp_is_safe_helper, this asks, hey
are _Iter1 and _Iter2
contiguous iterators, and that the
iterators don't point to volatile stuff.
So this is where volatility
is being excluded.
OK, so I believe that's correct,
but I think a comment needs to be changed,
so one of the things I look for when
code is significantly changing, is that
if there are any comments around,
it is quite possible to change the code
such that the comments become inaccurate.
So double checking the comments
for validity is important.
Here, the volatile check is being removed,
we've got this big comment here, and
this was describing the old code.
It said _Elem1 and _Elem2
aren't top level const because we
remove_const_t in an outer layer.
And then we talk about integral types
being eligible when they can't be volatile,
and this was intended to
map to this check here.
That's no longer here,
so I think at a minimum,
this comment needs to be updated.
Either we just need to strike
this bit about volatility,
or probably better, we should just add
some parenthetical note like, this being-
this is being checked, in –
What was the layer?
_Equal_memcmp_is_safe_helper, or we could
just describe that it's checked before
using this. So I will ask that.
OK.
[under breath] get back to go. backtick. backtick.
OK, it looks like the is-
We'll just grab the whole thing.
etc. checks are being lifted
up to the (and get the other thing…)
[under breath] Where is it? Here.
Iterator is volatile, so it's the
_Equal_memcmp_is- – what I want to do is double
click but it grabs the space at the end.
I guess I'll take it and delete the space.
Oh it pastes without the space,
interesting,
_Equal_memcmp_is_safe_helper layer,
which is fine. However,
I or– However, the comment.
They can't be volatile.
[unintellegible]
Ope, I don't want a space there.
The comment they can't be volatile above
was referring to the checks
that have been moved
Should this comment,
or, should we add a parenthetical
note to this comment mentioning
that volatility?
That's the right phrasing.
Here we said we remove_const_t
before using _Can_memcmp_elements,
I can just copy that, volatility
has already then handled similar to the
comment above. OK, see if that makes sense.
It looks like the
!is_volatile_v<_Elem1>, etc.
checks are being lifted up to the
_Equal_memcmp_is_safe_helper layer, which is fine,
however the comment they can't be
volatile above was referring to
the checks that have been moved.
Should we add a parenthetical
note to this comment mentioning
the volatility has already been
handled similar to the because we
remove_const_t before using
_Can_memcmp_elements comment above? OK.
Yeah, this is,
although this is all like variable
template metaprogramming,
really it's a question of, like,
preconditions and postconditions. Here, there,
this thing is assuming certain things
about its inputs, that they're not
const cause that's already been
handled, that they're not volatile,
because volatility has already been handled.
So we're just really documenting
our preconditions,
which is important because there's
no real way to debug through this
stuff when it's variable templates.
OK, next up, uh,
we had included a performance
note in the old code saying, hey,
if you're trying to compare like
int* to void*, we're just
not gonna bother to handle that.
That is now being handled by
the new _Is_pointer_address_comparable stuff.
So that comment's going away,
so that's great.
So here this is,
after the case of we can handle same
size integrals, uhm, which handles
the usual arithmetic conversions.
We have various other special cases like
this one which was previously added.
We can compare std::bytes even
though they're not integral, here
if we have pointers to some underlying
_Ty1 and _Ty2 elements,
We used to say we can compare
them only if they're the same,
pointing to the same element type.
Ignoring CV qualifiers.
This says if you're comparing two ranges
and the range elements themselves
are int* and const int*,
then those are different types.
But comparing them,
we know that comparing each pair
of pointers is not going to adjust any
bits in the pointers, in the addresses,
so we can just call memcmp
on the whole thing.
This optimization I think,
actually goes back to the original
implementation we had, circa 2007 or
so, when I started working here,
and it's been extended since then.
So, that retains that behavior, and then
additionally extends it to, oh! if
you're comparing int* to void*,
we know that is not going to do any
sort of weird address conversions.
And that's now all centralized
in _Is_pointer_address_comparable,
so that's good, like that. OK.
Now this is being refactored.
There used to be _Pred_is_consistent_with_memcmp.
this is now called _Can_memcmp_elements_with_pred.
So let's read the new explanation.
_Can_memcmp_elements_with_pred<_Elem1, _Elem2, _Pr>,
making sure that it matches the names,
reports whether the memcmp
optimization is applicable given
contiguously stored elements,
this avoids having to repeat
the metaprogramming that finds
the element types. OK.
_Elem1 and _Elem2 aren't top level const here.
OK,
this is talking about how we've already
handled the top level constness,
and this replaces the old stuff about…
thing about just whether
the predicate invocation
is transparent, uh,
and this was always kind of weird,
so I'm glad to see that going away.
OK, so this is handling
equal_to, OK, so,
with equal_to<_Elem3>.
Yeah, that's the name, we need to
make sure that both _Elem1 and _Elem2
are convertible to _Elem3 without
changing object representation.
We use _Iter_copy_cat for this task.
And _Elem3 can be safely
memcmp'd with itself.
OK, that makes sense
because we're, on input,
we're converting _Elem1 and _Elem2 each to _Elem3.
So that needs to not change object
representation, and then within equal_to,
that comparison, we need to see,
hey, can we use memcmp for that, so
template on class _Elem1, _Elem2, _Elem3,
_INLINE_VAR constexpr bool
_Can_memcmp_elements_with_pred for 1, 2, and
if the predicate type happens to
be exactly equal_to<_Elem3>,
and I was just thinking, ohh, but what if
_Elem3 is void, and we've got uh,
specialization down here handling that,
so here we know _Elem3 is not void.
So we're going to answer,
or ask three questions.
It looks ugly because of clang-format.
First, we ask, uh, the _Iter_copy_cat,
if we were going to copy
from _Elem1* to _Elem3*,
we're just forming pointers,
even though, we're forming imaginary pointers,
these aren't actually being passed to us.
If that is _Trivially_constructible,
that says without changing
object representation,
I don't know if I believe this because we
also want them to be the same size.
I need to go look this up, because
something like, say unsigned char
to unsigned short.
That's not, that's trivial as far
as the standard is concerned,
but it's going to widen the elements
by inserting, you know, extra zeros, so
we can't, like, memcmp them in place.
OK, so I'm gonna check that.
Then I ask the same question for _Elem2*
to _Elem3*,
_Trivially_constructible,
and can we memcmp elements
_Elem3 to _Elem3.
This ignores top level CV.
OK.
It's interesting that it's ignoring
top level volatility.
OK.
OK I was gonna check _Trivially_constructible,
so that's in the _Iter_copy_cat,
we're on line 4564, see if we can
find that, _Trivially_constructible.
OK, this asks are you _Pointer_address_convertible
and are you is_trivially_constructible_v.
This is the bit from the core language.
Is this the thing that's going
to require them to be the same size.
I'm a little nervous that we are sort
of introducing new concepts – [laughs] there I go,
saying concepts – new ideas,
that do not map to the standard type traits.
When I see _Trivially_constructible,
I'm generally assuming that we're referring
to like std::is_trivially_constructible_v.
It begins to be worrisome when we
start introducing extra conventions,
especially attached to existing terminology.
We've… we've already had
issues in the STL,
they haven't really caused bugs yet,
but we just have to
be real careful about it,
where we have type traits that are
sensitive to things like top level
CV qualifiers, where the standard
primary type categories are not,
and we haven't really done a
good rigorous job of documenting
exactly which things care about
top level CVs, and which don't.
Uhm,
that's like one layer of issues,
that we've successfully handled so far,
maybe we'll need to do something
about that in the future,
but this is like one step
beyond CV qualifiers.
So let me let me check this
_Pointer_address_convertible.
I'm pretty sure this is the one
that requires the same size.
Oh, here we go,
here's the _Trivially_constructible that's
saying same size and compatible.
This is _Trivial_cat, _Trivially_constructible,
_Is_pointer_address_convertible.
This is when you're just
pointers to _Source and _Dest.
Oh if the things themselves are
pointers, then we know,
of course, they're the same size,
but if they're not necessarily
both pointers here,
then that's when we require
them to be the same size.
Yeah, this, uh,
I'm more nervous about this,
it does mean that the usage below is fine,
uh, which is why I was
originally looking at this.
We were on 4564 I think.
Yeah, we were around here.
It is nested. That's the thing
that makes it kind of OK,
it's nested within _Iter_copy_cat.
But now that I'm looking at this,
the second time,
I'm increasingly uncomfortable
with the fact that we just see
_Trivially_constructible here,
and it expands to something more
precise and more restrictive than
just trivial constructibility.
I'm going to add a comment about this
because it's really a comment about naming.
It could be addressed by introducing
either different names or more clear names.
Like one of the… sort of the
only thing that makes this whole
metaprogramming thing bearable, is that
our names are generally pretty precise.
When I see something like,
you know, _Iterators_are_contiguous.
As long as we've you know, carefully
verified the definition of this thing,
I don't need to worry too much about
the actual usage because the type trait,
you know, says what it does.
But when something says _Trivially_constructible
and it's doing something different,
then it's an opportunity
to get confused, either in cases where
we really do want the more general
form given to us by the standard and
we're using something for convenience
that happens to be more restrictive,
or vice versa, which I think is more likely.
We want this more restrictive form that
has tests like same size and compatible,
but if we accidentally never go
through this centralized machinery,
we start getting the wrong answer.
And the usage would look like, what if
on like 4564 if we accidentally
didn't say, like,
_Iter_copy_cat::_Trivially_constructible, if we just
said, like, is_trivially_constructible_v,
that would be super bad.
And if the name were anything different,
that didn't mirror the standard
wording so much, I wouldn't be nervous,
because when I see some new name,
either a new arrangement of words or
ideally different words entirely,
then I don't come to it with those
assumptions from reading the standard,
like when I see, what was it,
_Same_size_and_compatible,
yeah, this does not map to
anything existing in the STL,
so if I see this, A. it tells me what it does,
but B. I know I need to look
up the definition to check,
OK, what does it mean
"compatible". It's that in fact,
that _Trivially_constructible
is using the same words,
but then is adding extra things.
I don't know if I necessarily want
you know like _Same_size_and_compatible_trivially_constructible
or something, but,
this, I think, I'm concerned
about it so I'm gonna comment.
I think it's these three that
I care about now.
Here, oh, I don't wanna – I don't
wanna get that.
I guess it gives me no choice because
this is what I would get in-line.
I'll just comment on this
one line and I'll say that
all of them are affected. OK.
After reading
usage of these.
[under breath] what should I call them? Constants?
Let's just say, after reading
usage far below these definitions.
I'm increasingly uncomfortable with,
and let's be explicit about exactly
which ones, _Trivially_constructible,
_Trivially_assignable,
and,
_Trivially_constructible_and_assignable, using
Standard-terminology words, as seen in
is_trivially_constructible_v etc,
but adding additional conditions,
specifically _Same_size_and_compatible.
In all of these layers of
complicated metaprogramming,
clear naming
is the only thing
preventing massive confusion.
I believe we should choose
different names for these
properties. So we…
to avoid any confusion,
[under breath] conversion, confusion,
confusion between
is_trivially_constructible_v
and _Trivially_constructible, etc.
They don't need to be
super duper verbose, for example,
Make a example here…
_Same_size_and_compatible_and_trivially_constructible
is probably too verbose, but
introducing a different word
somewhere, somehow could really help.
No specific ideas yet.
Hopefully this makes sense.
After reading usage far below
these definitions, I'm increasingly
uncomfortable with _Trivially_constructible.
Let me say – let me say the
naming, 'cause the logic is fine.
The naming of,
using standard terminology words,
At the – I'll just note it,
I'll just note it at the end.
The logic is fine, this is
purely a naming concern. OK.
After reading usage far
below these definitions,
I'm increasingly uncomfortable with
the naming of _Trivially_constructible,
_Trivially_assignable, and
_Trivially_constructible_and_assignable using
standard terminology words as seen
in is_trivially_constructible_v,
etc., by adding additional conditions
specifically _Same_size_and_compatible,
in all these layers of
complicated metaprogramming,
clear naming is the only thing
preventing massive confusion.
I believe we should choose different
names for these properties to avoid any
confusion between is_trivially_constructible_v
and _Trivially_constructible, etc.
They don't need to be super duper verbose,
for example,
_Same_size_and_compatible_and_trivially_constructible
is probably too
verbose, but introducing a different word
somewhere, somehow, could really help.
No specific ideas yet.
The logic is fine,
this is purely a naming concern.
OK, but we've got the
_Same_size_and_compatible condition,
which excludes bool shenanigans.
So we don't need to worry about
unsigned char and unsigned short
somehow activating memcmp,
which would be bad.
OK, so let's resume 4564.
OK, so this is good,
this is generalized.
Ah, OK.
Now,
If our predicate happens to
be equal_to<>,
then we know we're just going
to directly compare _Elem1, _Elem2
so we can immediately ask
_Can_memcmp_elements.
This does not remove any CVS.
Do we do that above?
_Equal_memcmp_is_safe_helper.
OK, this calls it with _Iter_value_t,
and the iterator value type is
not gonna have any CV qualifiers.
OK, so, we don't need
to worry about that here.
In fact, this is sort of… No, no,
somebody very strange could say
equal_to<const int>, so removing
CV on the _Elem3 is good here. OK.
OK, so no reason to worry
about CV qualifiers there. Next,
ranges::equal_to is also transparent,
so if we're in concepts mode and
our comparator is ranges::equal_to,
then just _Can_memcmp_elements. That's good.
Ah OK, finally, _Equal_memcmp_is_safe.
We've got a helper.
It's being refactored a little.
It reports whether we can activate
the memcmp optimization for
arbitrary iterators and predicates.
It ignores top-level constness on
the iterators and on the elements.
So, _INLINE_VAR constexpr bool _Equal_memcmp_is_safe_helper,
we first answer are the iterators contiguous.
They better be if we're gonna call memcmp.
_Iter1 had better not be
an iterator to volatile.
Same for _Iter2,
it should not be iterator to
volatile and we need to be able to
memcmp elements with pred,
_Iter_value_t<_Iter1>, the _Iter_value_t<_Iter2>,
and the predicate.
OK.
OK, onward to lexicographical compare.
Here we're placing this logic,
and I'm sort of skipping over the old logic
cause I'm pretty familiar with it,
I should be referring to
it a little bit more,
but I've reviewed this in the past,
so when I've seen missing things here,
it just sort of inherently jumps out to me.
template<_Elem1, _Elem2>
_INLINE_VAR constexpr bool _Lex_compare_memcmp_classify_elements.
OK, there was no preamble comment to this.
It's probably fine.
I think we commented below. Do we?
Yeah, we don't. We just go
straight into _Lex_compare.
On the other hand,
that's sort of preexisting.
We had comments on some of these
definitions, OK, I'm not,
I'm not gonna ask for a comment there.
Maybe in the future we should add one.
template<_Elem1, _Elem2>
_INLINE_VAR constexpr bool _Lex_compare_memcmp_classify_elements,
is_conjunction_v,
all these things need to be true.
_Elem1, and because
we're going to _Lex_compare,
they need to be byte-sized.
_Elem1 needs to be a character or a bool,
_Elem2 needs to be a character or a bool,
_Elem1 needs to be unsigned,
_Elem2 needs to be unsigned.
OK, and this actually does
map to what we had before,
except now it permits bool.
Is that reasonable?
Can you do bool less than unsigned char?
Yes you can, because the bool will widen.
Actually, we promote it all the way to int,
but you can definitely less than that.
bool less than bool, that works.
In fact we recently saw usage of that with
less than equal or greater than equal.
And, enums. Those I think would
not be reported by _Is_character…
It's a good question –
_Is_character_or_bool.
Let's – let's check that.
I should have just been
reviewing this in VS Code.
Let's see if we can get this… search.
OK, so this is elsewhere, in
<xutility> 4329. Here we go.
This reports true for bool,
of course. It reports true for char,
signed char, unsigned char, and char8_t.
It does not report true for anything else.
And here's an example of what
I was talking about – it
does not strip top level
const qualifiers.
It will reort true only for exactly bool, char,
signed char, unsigned char, or char8_t.
Because that's interesting, we do not
check enums, ohh, but enums are not
less than comparable by default, I think.
Yeah, oh, well enum classes are not,
I think enums get promoted.
I don't… I don't know the enum rules
well enough without looking them up.
I don't use them that often,
it's certainly not a regression.
We didn't try to handle enums before.
is_unsigned will report things correctly,
at least for plain enums,
I believe. It asks, what if
you had negative one?
I know for enums you do need
to provide bitmask operators.
I think for enum classes you
don't get less than, you
actually need to provide it.
I think this is fine. I'm not gonna
worry too much about enums here.
In theory we could extend the optimization,
but we would need to know that the
comparison operator is not overloaded.
The nice thing about characters
or bools is they're not user defined,
so there's no way there can be
weird overloaded operators.
I think that's probably what's
preventing us from doing anything here.
When we're copying, we know,
hey, you've got an enum,
there's no way you could
overload a copy assignment operator,
but for comparisons I think you could
have a user defined operator<.
OK, so then if we're bytes,
OK, this is, uh, this is a conformance bug.
Oh, no, sorry! It's not!
[laughs] It's __cpp_lib_byte.
The classic gotcha that we
have is saying template<>
_INLINE_VAR is incorrect
if you're in C++14 mode.
Because you, it's technically
non-conformant to explicitly
specialize the variable template,
without inline.
However, if you are inline,
it's totally cool. This is OK,
because __cpp_lib_byte implies C++17.
What that actually means is
this should be plain inline.
I should actually check.
I think we do have cases where, I think
in fact it might be above, where
when we know we're __cpp_lib_byte,
we just say inline directly.
Yeah, here it is.
_Can_memcmp, yeah, here's the [unintelligible]
_Can_memcmp_elements because it's a
C++14 available thing is _INLINE_VAR.
When __cpp_lib_byte is defined,
we are definitely in 17 or above mode.
So we can say plain inline constexpr bool.
We should follow the exact same pattern here.
Let me just copy this whole thing.
Actually I can – I can cite it.
Um, four, no, that's right line.
Left line 4513 in <xutility>
Let's get this. OK, so stl, inc,
I should add a little search
engine that lets me type something
like inc and then a file
name and it will take me there.
I should really do that.
<xutility>.
Yeah, we just need to
autocomplete this part here.
I said 4513.
Down, scroll up. There it is.
OK, hit Y for permalink.
I want to, oh it's click and drag.
Nope, no, it's shift click.
Trying to remember which
UI we're looking at.
Excuse me, yeah, OK,
this is what I wanna quote.
It has to be permalink for the inline
snippet to show in the comment.
We don't need this anymore.
OK, this is nitpick level
now, it's not needed for correctness
because it will expand to inline,
but it does follow the existing
convention. We were in the __cpp_lib_byte
case for _Lex_compare … something or other.
Yeah, here it is. #ifdef __cpp_lib_byte.
No, I don't wanna comment
on that whole thing, no.
OK, maybe just this line? Will you cooperate?
OK, here we go.
Let me paste the thing, OK. Copy this, OK.
As this is guarded by __cpp_lib_byte,
we should say plain inline here, see:
OK. #ifdef __cpp_lib_byte. As this
is guarded by __cpp_lib_byte,
we should say plain inline here,
see: #ifdef __cpp_lib_byte
allow memcmp'ing and so forth, OK.
OK, so if we're being asked
to compare byte versus byte,
we will report true. OK, that's good.
That's what we were doing before here,
except we had to repeat byte three times. OK.
And if we don't recognize the
thing we report void for the _Pred,
which is how we say, hey,
you're not actually comparable.
OK, Ohh wow this looks kind of terrible.
Just 'cause it's so severely wrapped.
OK, so we are specializing.
_Lex_compare_memcmp_classify_pred.
This is the primary template.
So if we don't recognize it, it's void.
But if we are specifically _Elem1,
_Elem2, and less<_Elem3>,
then we might be eligible.
So we're gonna ask if
comparing _Elem3's
could be done with _Lex_compare,
because that's the comparison
that's actually gonna happen, then
we need to make sure that going
from _Elem1 to _Elem3, and _Elem2 to _Elem3,
doesn't do weird conversions.
So this uses the type traits we
just asked about the naming,
_Iter_copy_cat from an an imaginary _Elem1*
to an _Elem3*,
if that's trivial,
meaning same size and compatible,
and it's trivial.
Then you're not gonna mess with
the bit representation at all,
and less'ing them is good.
And, we don't need to worry about
usual arithmetic conversions because
they're both being coerced to _Elem3,
so we don't need to worry about
like an _Elem1 being wider or something
and overpowering _Elem3.
_Elem3 is always the destination,
and similarly _Elem2 to _Elem3,
_Trivially_constructible.
OK, then return less<int>.
This is, as we saw last time, will be
used to compare the output of memcmp,
so it always needs to be int.
Otherwise just return void.
OK, good.
less<> is transparent,
so you can,
or we can, immediately skip
any concern about that.
We just directly ask. Hey is _Elem1 and _Elem2,
are they _Lex_comparable?
If so, return less<int>,
otherwise void, OK.
greater needs to reverse the sense,
so same pattern.
Gotta be careful for copy-pastoes,
we would compare _Elem3 versus _Elem3.
Here the fact that the comparison
sense is reversed doesn't matter.
It's going to be comparable through memcmp
either way, the reverseness
happens here, and then go from
_Elem1 to _Elem3 and from _Elem2 to _Elem3.
They both say pointers,
so that's good.
OK,
greater<> is also transparent.
So this is good,
_Elem1 and _Elem2, greater<int>, void, OK.
So for ranges, guarded
by #ifdef __cpp_lib_concepts,
If we see ranges::less, we know it's
transparent, so we can do this short form.
I was just thinking, should we just
derive from the other specialization?
But that would really be the same.
It would be one line,
one extra line of code and it
would instantiate more stuff.
Better to just repeat this here.
So ranges::less,
compare _Elem1, _Elem2, report less<int>.
For ranges::greater, report
std::greater<int>, that's good.
OK, it's now the top level
_Lex_compare_memcmp_classify.
We're gonna ask
for _It1, _It2, and _Pred.
I was briefly thinking about, is that
the usual naming we have?
Usually we say things like
_Iter, but _It is fine.
So _It1 and _It2 need to be
contiguous, and _It1 needs to be
not volatile and not an iterator
to volatile. Same for _It2,
had better not be iterator volatile; then,
if that's true, emit typename ::_Pred
from _Lex_compare_memcmp_classify_pred,
give it the _Iter_value_t,
this will not have any CV qualifiers.
_Iter_value_t<_It2> and the _Pred.
OK. This is sort of preexisting.
I am not a fan of shadowing.
This is not technically shadowing,
but this is using _Pred in two
different sentences, so when I see this,
my brain momentarily short circuits.
This is fine, though.
I mean it's prexisting.
We did avoid it before by having _Pr,
at least in the template.
I guess we do use _Pred elsewhere.
Where do we,
do we use _Pred elsewhere? Or is it _Pr?
We could avoid this cheaply by saying _Pr.
We say _Pr here.
This avoids the duplication
by saying class _Pr.
Did we say _Pred at the
memcmp_classify level?
Ohh, it used to be a function.
And now it's a … that's a helper here.
I'm going to ask for it to be,
just class _Pr, 'cause it's a
little more consistent with what
we did above and it avoids
this weird quasi-shadowing.
Do we have any other cases of
class _Pred that I would need to comment on?
That's the only one.
OK, let me see.
Maybe I'll comment on the whole thing
just so the context is clear.
Naming nitpick: I recommend
templating on class _Pr here,
which would be more consistent
with, and let's get the use of
class _Pr above – this one –
with the definition of
blah above, and would avoid the
quasi-shadowing that appears in
this horrible thing. Not really
horrible, it's just verbose.
Ok, naming nitpick:
I recommend templating on
class _Pr here,
which would be more consistent
with the definition of
_Lex_compare_memcmp_classify_pred above
and would avoid the quasi-shadowing
that appears in
typename _Lex_compare_memcmp_classify<MEOW, _Pred>::_Pred.
OK. So now,
we're going directly to
lexicographical_compare. Before we had functions,
_Lex_compare_unchecked.
Here.
And now it's all being inlined. OK.
So that's where all that complexity is going.
That's good, these multiple
layers are sort of a holdover,
often from our previous
tag dispatch era, when we didn't have
if constexpr, and we didn't
have things like decltype,
so we really needed another layer of
a function template to deduce the
unwrapped types, and to switch between
I can optimize versus
I can't. Now that we have if constexpr
unconditionally, even in C++14 mode,
because we can always use future technology
when we ask the compiler devs, pretty please.
And we have
things like decltype,
we no longer need separate layers
of functions.
Sometimes we still want functions
for helpers, like with, you know,
_Copy_unchecked, but sometimes, inlining
it is just easier.
And that's the case here.
Umm, so now std::lexicographical_compare?
Which is a lot of syllables.
We're adding top level constness,
for our most modern convention on
everything, except for the predicate,
that could have a non-const function call
operator for all we know.
We verify the iterators are in the right order.
We unwrap them.
We're removing the constness on
_UFirst1 and _UFirst2,
because we're actually going to
iterate through them, because we're
actually doing the fundamental loop.
So that's where that's going.
Now we're gonna ask, OK,
the _Memcmp_pred,
which is the thing we're gonna
compare the memcmp answer from.
We're gonna _Lex_compare_memcmp_classify
the decltype of the unwrapped iterator,
same for the decltype of the unwrapped
second iterator, and the _Pr. if constexpr
so let's see if we're eligible
for the optimization.
If _Memcmp_pred is not void,
then we are eligible.
So let's do something cool.
But wait!
If we're in _HAS_CXXX20 mode,
then we are required to be
constexpr.
This memcmp thing is incompatible at compile time.
So we need a runtime test that says
if we're in 20 mode then we had better
not be std::is_constant_evaluated.
Only then at runtime can we
do this cool thing.
If we turn out to be actually
being invoked for compile time,
this will turn out to be false
and we'll end up doing the raw
loop that is constexpr friendly.
So this pattern is quite
common throughout the STL,
and if we're not eligible
at all for the optimization,
we never even bother asking that,
we constant evaluate it, thanks
to the wonders of if constexpr.
This also explains why this
is not an if constexpr else,
because we do need this fall through
in the case that the runtime test
falls through and as a final aside,
it is extremely intentional that this is not
if constexpr (is_constant_evaluated),
the compiler will actually warn
at you if you do that,
because that forces the answer
to always be yes,
it is constant evaluated,
which is not what you want.
This needs to be expressed as a runtime test.
OK, so if we end up being
eligible at compile time and
runtime for the optimization,
we get the differences of the
iterators, and that's the number
of elements we're looking at.
We static_cast from ptrdiff_t to size_t.
We know that they're in the right order
because we verified them so we don't
need to worry about reverse things.
We call our helper memcmp taking a count.
We give it the unwrapped raw pointers
or unwrapped iterators and we're gonna
compare for the lesser of _Num1 and _Num2
elements, we use std::min,
parenthesize to avoid macro expansion,
get the answer out,
this is very similar to what we had before,
and then we compare. If it is
less than zero, if it is,
less than meaning as judged by the pred,
this handles the reverting …
the reversing of behavior.
Then we'll immediately return that.
So if it ends up being
less than zero, we'll return that.
Otherwise, if it's greater than zero,
we definitely want to return false.
If it's exactly equal to 0,
the only way we can return true is
if _Num1 one is less than _Num2,
meaning the first sequence is shorter.
This handles the prefix case where
cat is considered less than catastrophe.
If you had a sequence of char.
This is exactly equivalent
to what we had before.
This also, by the way,
this correctly handles the case where
the comparator is std::greater,
that only – if you pass std::greater as
the comparison, that only affects the
answer when the elements compare non-equal.
A lexicographical_compare with std::greater will
still say that a shorter sequence is
considered lexicographically
before the longer sequence.
It doesn't reverse that part,
because in some sense, lexicographical_compare
doesn't know that it's
reversing at all.
Maybe it's only comparing the
sizes of strings or something.
It just has a rule.
If all the elements are
considered equivalent,
then shorter sequence is
lexicographically before longer sequence.
OK, so that's good.
Next, here we go,
so I guess the conclusion is
that what that means is that
sorting a sequence of strings
by lexicographic std::less
and then sorting it …
sorry, comparing them with std::greater
is not the same as just doing it with
std::less and then reversing it, because
it's going to handle different length
strings differently, if that makes any sense.
OK, otherwise, if we are not eligible
for the memcmp optimization, like
we're dealing with user defined types
or if we are in constexpr land,
we need to do the raw loop, and so we iterate.
We've initialized everything already,
so as long as _UFirst1 is not _ULast1
and _UFirst2 is not _ULast2,
we have elements of both sequences,
we can do the comparison. At the
end of the loop, we'll increment _UFirst1,
we'll increment _UFirst2.
We've got this void cast here to handle
overloaded operator comma because
being a standard library implementer
is fun.
We have to defend against all sorts of
interesting user behavior.
Something to compare.
Do it.
We're gonna compare *_UFirst1
against *_UFirst2 using the _Pred; We will
run it through our _DEBUG_LT_PRED helper.
This detects cases where the user
predicate is incorrect and returns true
when an element is less than itself.
That should never ever happen.
This detects incorrect use
of, like, less_equal.
So if it's considered less
than we return true,
Otherwise we'll reverse it,
and if two is less than one,
we'll return false.
Otherwise,
we'll keep going,
because they're equivalent. At the end,
they are lexicographically less
only when the first sequence is
shorter than the second; that happens when
_UFirst1 has been exhausted,
it's equal to _ULast1,
and _UFirst2 is not exhausted,
it's not equal to _ULast2.
So this is translating, in fact,
basically moving this code
around that was already up here.
GitHub doesn't show moves,
but, it's just a move.
If I was extremely paranoid,
I would diff before and after
as I do elsewhere. Here,
the code is straightforward enough that I
can visually see that it's all correct,
and it hasn't been mutated in any weird way.
OK,
so that is for.
lexicographical_compare with a pred.
Now we have lexicographical_compare without a pred.
This one is just gaining const on
all the iterators.
Nothing else is happening here.
I don't actually know why …
I guess it's too much of a change
for GitHub to highlight
const four times in this case,
but that's what's happening.
And then we just passed less<>, OK?
For the parallel version,
_ExPo&&.
These are all const-ifying.
OK, this one's not being parallelized right now,
so we just call the std version.
OK,
that's good.
This one is the one that doesn't
even take a pred, but it's parallel.
Again, we're adding const to all the iterators.
OK. Yep. OK, now in the concepts
world this is the _Lex_compare_three_way
for the <=> operator.
OK, so. Template on _Elem1, _Elem2,
_Cmp, I'm always scanning for non-ugly names.
This is the _Lex_compare_three_way_memcmp_classify_cmp
By default, not eligible.
We report void,
but, if we're given the std::compare_three_way
function object then we might be eligible.
So using _Comp = conditional_t …
We're gonna ask, can we
_Lex_compare_memcmp_classify_elements<_Elem1, _Elem2>.
This uses the memcmp thing we defined above,
because ultimately that's what we wanna do.
We wanna ask,
hey, are you memcmp-able?
But we also need to make sure,
are these elements just
three way comparable at all?
So is it, and this standard, I want to
say this is a concept, three_way_comparable_with,
const _Elem1& versus const _Elem2&.
If that's true we'll return compare_three_way,
using the same sort of,
this is what we're gonna compare
memcmp's result with, otherwise void.
OK, we've got some internal concepts,
this is all guarded by __cpp_lib_concepts.
That's because not all of our front ends
support concepts yet, they will soon!
Then this will just turn to _HAS_CXX_20.
So if we are given _Ty1 and _Ty2,
_Can_strong_order requires, given a
const _Ty1& _Left, and a const _Ty2& _Right,
we can call strong_order(_Left, _Right)?
This is, interestingly,
a function object in the STL,
so we do not qualify it.
I think
it's not technically a function,
so it's not vulnerable to ADL.
I think the existing convention is
we don't qualify it,
but I can't remember if we
actually call this.
Ooh, that's interesting.
So here I did end up –
I think I wrote this code –
Yeah, this is familiar.
I did qualify this, because
it looks like a function.
Yeah, this is qualified here too.
It's technically not.
Here, we made sure that strong_ordering
was not in scope,
and then we're doing ADL call.
I would feel better with a _STD here.
It is more consistent with existing usage.
I can quote this.
This is in <compare> line 700.
It's a nitpick.
That's influenced by how
much I hate and fear
ADL, the argument dependent lookup that
we're constantly on guard against.
When I see the qualification,
I'm like, ohh, no ADL, this is,
you know, fun and happy.
And when I don't see the qualification,
I'm like, oh, could this be ADL?
Could we be hijacked by a better overload?
[under breath] Where's <compare>? Here we go.
I wanted – nope, I don't want this PR.
On line 3…, no, line 700.
That's, ope,
and I've got the PR up.
Sorry about that.
Whenever I tap my trackpad,
it becomes a click, OK, here we go.
Get a permalink by pressing Y.
Here's the call to std::strong_order.
OK, going inside <utility>, this
occurs to all these. So, nitpick:
Although this
technically isn't a function,
and therefore is invulnerable to ADL –
I can expand this for any
viewers out there who are not versed
in the standard acronyms – Argument
Dependent – and I don't do this for everything,
like SFINAE, but may as well.
This is also not universally known – Lookup.
We've conventionally
qualified it elsewhere,
just to avoid any confusion.
Occurs below for
weak_order and partial_order.
Example of … or example precedent?
[unintelligible]
Nitpick: although this technically
isn't a function and therefore is
invulnerable to Argument Dependent Lookup,
we've conventionally qualified
elsewhere just to avoid any confusion.
Occurs below for weak_order and
partial_order. Example precedent:
return _STD strong_order(_Left, _Right). OK.
Ohh, and this just occurred to me.
This is called _Can_strong_order, that thing
in <compare> was called _Can_strong_order.
[under breath] thought it was here, _Can_strong_order.
That's nested within the fallback.
It's nested within this namespace.
Technically … it is actually shadowing
like there's a std::_Can_strong_order
if that's been included above,
although here I think <compare> is actually
included above, but it's the same name.
I'm really uncomfortable whenever I
see the same name reused in the STL,
even if there's no actual shadowing.
I would prefer any other name;
that, or lift this up.
Like here, the only reason I
nested it in was because I didn't
think anybody else needed it.
But if we actually do need it now …
This is trying to call the
std function object that we've defined.
Lifting this out would be better.
One fewer concept and no shadowing.
Let me suggest that.
OK, so let me …
shift-select this, excuse me.
OK.
Just comment on maybe this
thing. There we go.
Actually, this
I'm gonna say … I'm gonna say
duplicates … this appears to …
[unintelligible] not 100% sure …
this appears to duplicate
the helper in <compare>.
template … yep, it's concept, _Can_strong_order.
It's testing the std function object.
Yeah, looks exactly the same.
If they are indeed exactly the same,
testing whether we can use the
Standard function object.
Lift it out of – let me copy the namespace.
I recommend extracting the
helper in <compare> out of
namespace _Compare_strong_order_fallback
so it can be used here.
This would avoid any
quasi-shadowing/confusion.
OK, how's that look?
And I need to say, occurs
for the following concepts too.
I had nested the helper concepts in
their namespaces since I didn't expect
any further use of them,
but didn't intend to prevent wider use, OK.
This appears to duplicate the
helper in <compare>:
concept _Can_strong_order,
if they are indeed exactly the same,
testing whether we can use
the standard function object,
I recommend extracting the helper
in <compare> out of
namespace _Compare_strong_order_callback
so it can be used here.
This would avoid any
quasi-shadowing/confusion.
Occurs for the following concepts too.
I had nested the helper concepts
in their namespaces since I didn't
expect any further use of them,
but didn't intend to prevent wider use.
OK. _Can_weak_order, _Can_partial_order.
OK, getting close to the end of <xutility>.
Let me check real quick, we're around line 5000.
We are almost at the end?
Yeah, we're almost at the end.
OK, I'll get to the end of this file and
we'll call this a review or a video review.
We still have more files to look at.
OK, here's the end of the concepts.
OK, let's see.
Is this all added?
No, we're going back to deletions.
template on _Elem1, _Elem2,
_Lex_compare_three_way_memcmp_classify_comp,
given _Elem1, _Elem2, and the strong_order customization point object,
This is the type of the
std::strong_order function object,
using _Comp.
So we are,
if we're given strong_order,
We're going to ask,
can we _Lex_compare_memcmp_classify_elements<_Elem1, _Elem2>,
and can we strong_order
_Elem1, _Elem2 meaning can we call the
std::strong_order function object on them.
Then let's emit strong_order CPO.
Otherwise void, OK.
For weak_order, same question,
can we use memcmp?
Can we weak_order?
Here, I'm looking for copy-pastoes,
if so emit weak_order CPO.
And, finally, for partial_order,
still can we memcmp one and
two, can we partial_order _Elem1, _Elem2?
If so, emit partial_order CPO, OK.
Now for class _It1, _It2, and _Comp,
the _Lex_compare_three_way_memcmp_classify,
given two iterators and a
comparator, we need to ask, are _It1 and
_It2 contiguous iterators, and _It1
is not an iterator volatile, and _It2
is not an iterator volatile.
And, if that's the case, then let's report
the _Comp returned by this. I see
the same quasi-shadowing that we
might be able to avoid with _Cmp,
so I'm gonna ask for that. Let's ask,
_Lex_compare_three_way_memcmp_classify_cmp,
give it the iter_value_t from _It1,
iter_value_t from _It2, and then _Comp.
OK, here I'm trying to catch cases where
we accidentally say like _It1, _It1
twice, which would be catastrophic
and missed in a lot of cases.
OK, so this is all good,
except quasi-shadowing,
so I'll ask for that. Let's see.
Similar issue as before,
can we use class _Cmp to
avoid the quasi-shadowing of …
or just avoid quasi-shadowing here.
class _Cmp, yep, that'd
be nice and distinct, OK.
And now the top-level function
for users, we're adding top-level const
to the iterators, all of them.
We already were not const-ifying
_UFirst1 and _UFirst2,
so no change there.
All of this is now being lifted up,
that's being extracted into those helpers,
so we can ask here: the _Memcmp_pred,
let's call _Lex_compare_three_way_memcmp_classify
the decltype of _UFirst1,
and _UFirst2, and the _Cmp.
If it's not void,
then we're eligible at compile time.
We need to see if we're
eligible at runtime.
Here, the three way is always C++20,
so we don't need any
if C++20 stuff around here.
OK.
It's not constant evaluated,
then call memcmp.
If they end up being the same,
then we need to compare the
lengths with the memcmp _Pred.
Otherwise compare against zero.
So this is not
handling the greater thing.
This would be, this is very
different from the plain
lexicographical_compare, where we never wanted
to use the predicate that we
emitted to our metaprogramming
machinery on the lengths.
Here, the _Pred can't be greater or whatever.
It can only be
strong_order, weak_order, or partial_order.
Do I believe that? It can be user defined.
That's interesting,
I'm gonna need to double check that.
That's extremely interesting.
What if it's a user-defined
comparator that reverses the sense?
I'm going to need to check that.
This part is fine.
You compare against zero. OK.
This one's really interesting.
Uh, let me … lexicographical_compare_three_way …
we don't have any –
we don't have any test
coverage for custom
<=> comparators.
lexicographical_three – ohh compare_three_way.
Defined in clause 25.
Oh, OK, I think I think we're correct, so
this says in sort of mathematical terms,
find the smallest integer that
you see different elements,
so the first elements that don't match.
If you find one where it's not zero,
you just return it. If they all
end up happening to be equal to zero,
meaning they're all equivalent, then,
ohh, <=>-ize, always <=>.
OK, so this is very much like,
this is exactly like
the stand… the classic one where
the classical one says if the
comparison resolves before the end,
return whatever the comparator
said, so std::less, std::greater,
user less, user greater, whatever,
you return that, but, if they end
up all being equivalent elements,
then the shorter sequence is considered less
than, lexicographically less than, the greater.
You don't use the user comparator
there. This here says, let E(n)
be the user comparator on the
n-th elements of the sequences.
If the comparison –
if there are different elements
that we encounter, return the user comparison.
If you don't, then you ignore
the user comparison.
You directly open <=>
the lengths of these, so
the user comparison could be returning
a strong_ordering of, you know,
less or greater that's reversed.
It could be doing like a std::greater
type comparison,
but you are not supposed to
use it on this case.
So this says that we've got a bug.
We need test coverage for it as well,
OK?
And I guess I noticed this because
this pattern of using the _Memcmp_pred
twice did not occur for the
std::lexicographical_compare, the classic one.
So even though it does look like it's
consistent here that we're converting
these two <=>s over to the
_Memcmp_pred machinery, that difference
in pattern is what clued me in,
this is not what we want.
OK, so where is the bug?
I think the bug is with the _Num1s.
Because if memcmp finds a non-zero answer,
we found different elements.
So. Possibly here.
Actually, is this an issue?
Are we,
this may not be an issue.
We only activate this
for ones we recognize.
We only activate it for our strong_order,
weak_order, and partial_order,
not for user comparisons because we
don't know what they're gonna do,
so we can't possibly call
memcmp for them. Ah.
So at most, at most this is
unnecessarily generalized.
I think I'm still gonna ask
for it to be changed because we
can just say <=> here.
Yeah it affects the return – oh yeah,
ooh it – auto, ohh we would convert
the stronger to the weaker,
that's possible, right? Yeah?
It – I think it does
not affect observable behavior.
But, for clarity, I would prefer
to see a direct use of <=>.
I'll put it like that.
OK, and it's on the _Num1's because
if _Ans is not zero, then we should
return whatever this returns.
Is this whole thing auto?
The whole thing is auto.
Ohh sorry it's auto ->, so we've
already got the return type here.
Yeah I wanna see <=>, OK.
I'm going to comment here.
OK, ehh, these are horrible,
it says paragraph 3 of …
I really need a bigger text box.
I think big thoughts.
Thank you, OK.
And we are almost at time,
or slightly overtime.
WG21-N4892.
I Have memorized that number.
I'll keep the section number
in there for convenience.
I'm not gonna bother
with all the formatting.
Chop this out so it's not distracting.
I guess I am a little picky
and I'll put that in italics.
Gonna put some backticks here.
OK. Let's see.
Although I don't believe it
[under breath] actually, let me summarize this.
After some thought, I don't believe this affects correctness,
but I believe we should directly
<=> compare the
lengths here, instead of using the
_Memcmp_pred
returned by the metaprogramming.
This will match the standardese
and the classic lexicographical_compare
implementation more closely.
For the classic impl,
this is critical, as the
metaprogrammed machinery is
capable of reversing the ordering,
which we don't want to do for the
lengths of equal prefix sequences.
For the three way impl, this is cosmetic
as we activate the optimization only
for strong_order, I'm not going
to bother monospacing this, weak_order,
partial_order, none of which
reverse things like std::greater
do. OK. Lot of words.
WG21-N4892 alg.three.way/3
Returns … or (e1 - b1) <=> (e2 - b2)
if no such integer exists.
After some thought,
I don't believe this affects correctness,
but I believe we should directly.
Let me say, but for clarity.
After some thought,
I don't believe this affects correctness,
but for clarity I believe we should
directly <=> compare the lengths here
instead of using the _Memcmp_pred returned
by the metaprogramming, this will match
the standardese and the classic
lexicographical_compare implementation
more closely. For the classic impl,
this is critical as the metaprogramming
machinery is capable of reversing the
ordering which we don't want to
do for the lengths of equal prefix
sequences. For the three way impl,
this is cosmetic as we activate
the optimization only for strong_order,
weak_order, partial_order,
none of which reverse things
like std::greater do. OK.
And then add some top level const,
and we're all good.
No ranges stuff here, that I see.
OK, that is the end of <xutility>.
We can mark that as viewed.
OK, so let me alt click and
see what test code we have.
So we've got all the test code.
The only thing I had looked at was test.lst.
OK, most of it is new tests, or sorry,
it's these decomposed tests.
Some new, some decomposed.
OK, I will go ahead and submit
this review. Thanks –
part 2 of the …
or, thanks – reviewed this in part 2
of the video review.
Looked at the rest of <xutility>,
still need to review the test code.
OK. Comment.
OK so I asked for,
comment change about the volatility because
I was a little bit confused about that,
the renaming that I don't have any good
suggestions for, the inline, that's cosmetic.
Avoiding the quasi-shadowing
with _Pred.
Same with _Comp elsewhere.
And either std:: qualifying
this or just unifying them.
And I think it should actually be unified.
Uh, the _Comp as I mentioned and then
the final thing with the <=>.
So all cosmetic stuff/some clarity for naming?
But really no correctness concerns,
so, this is looking extremely
good and I think we're just gonna
need to look at the test code.
Oh, and it looks like Casey has also reviewed.
This can fail in the presence
of multiple inheritance,
since the pointer to base and the pointer
to derived can be equal but have differing
bit patterns. Is that true for
is_pointer_interconvertible?
I thought that's what …
>> Casey: [unintelligible]
>> Stephan: Yeah, this is user …
this is library defined.
This is why AdamBucior is defining.
But he uses is_pointer_interconvertible_base_of.
>> Casey: OK, never mind.
>> Stephan: But that's a good point.
We should have a test, ideally.
I can add a comment here.
I believe that the use of
>> Casey: I guess yeah, thank you.
>> Stephan: Yeah, I can't spell it.
I think it's is_pointer_interconvertible …
>> Casey: yeah, is_pointer_interconvertible.
>> Stephan: … base_of. This puppy.
>> Casey: There we go.
>> Stephan: Yeah.
handles this scenario,
but we should be sure to,
we should make sure
that there's test coverage for this
scenario. I haven't checked yet.
Yes, an excellent question,
because mishandling
this would be very bad.
Commented!
OK, cool, let's see.
Are there any questions for all
of the topics we covered?
OK, I'm not hearing any.
So I think we can call this the end of the
video code review.
I'll stop sharing my screen.
So thanks again for joining us; for next week
we may either continue looking at this,
or perhaps I'll go off and review the tests,
and we'll be looking at another PR next time,
so thanks and see you then!